let me start with this tweet before
we go right down the rabbit hole so this
guy Jeremy boring is the uh co-founder
of the daily wire which is probably the
biggest like right-wing tradcon sort of
space out there right now um I thought
it was hilarious the way that he handled
the
Gillette uh toxic masculinity bit
countering it with his own razors
countering the Hershey's uh you know
wokeness with his with his chocolate
bars so again entertaining agree with
much of what they say but again where
they get lost in the weeds and really
screw up things and Lead guys down um
into the slaughterhouse is with their
whole notion that you should just still
marry regardless of the difficulties
regardless of the environment regardless
of the laws regardless of regardless
they still say March in the
slaughterhouse so let me go and uh frame
this with his with his tweet which I
kind of discussed uh the other day
briefly on my um General show but I'm
going to go deeper down this on a solo
moment so if you watch that just bear
with me so Mr boring here um you can go
follow him on uh Twitter is he says he's
the co-founder of real real daily wire
and Jeremy's razors says the red pill
attack on marriage is evil divorce is
also evil no fault divorce is
particularly evil divorce when children
are in the picture is one of the most
evil acts a person can engage in well it
is what it is man you know uh people
part ways and I agree you know children
generally do better in a household where
there's two parents involved uh children
also generally do better when they're
raised by uh a single father versus a
single mother um statistically speaking
single fathers do a far better job than
single mothers and single fathers
basically do almost as as good a job as
a two parent household so there's that
as well um all of these acts of evil are
common because evil is common and we are
all given it from time to time but that
does not change what they are the notion
of of good versus evil is funny here the
way that it's Being Framed it's like
there's good and there's bad and that
side is bad so it's US versus them
basically is you know what it is and
we've always lived in an Us Versus Them
world Jack Donovan talks about it in the
way of men and his other stuff that's
what we are we're tribes you know the
way of men is the way of the gang as he
says so when he's talking about evil
he's he's trying to distinguish that
tribe over there anybody that says that
um you know marriage is a bad idea and
you know divorce is divorce as a
consequence of a bad marriage choice is
also a bad idea they're on that side
they're on the evil side so I guess by
definition I'm evil um all of these acts
of evil are common because evil is
common we are all given it from time to
time but that not but that does not
change who we are the fact that women
initiate 80% of divorce is evidence that
some manif ation of evil are more common
in women oo he's calling women evil now
something society and frustratingly
Christian Society has been trying to
obscure since we turned over all of our
moral authority to women in the 20th
century okay well you can blame the
churches for that dude like that's you
know it like all of the religious crowds
out there this guy inclusive with all of
his daily wire uh you know gang as well
um subscribe to organized religion you
know um some of them are Jewish some are
Christian catholic whatever it happens
to be but they all subscribe to a
certain organized religion which under
which falls under the umbrella of the uh
marriage or or some form of marriage as
they like to call it uh he goes on to
say it's also evidence of a deep
societal sickness one that creates
enormous incentives for women to divorce
and virtually though not absolutely none
for men so he's still blaming women here
the red pill rightly observe much of the
sickness they even rightly diagnose much
of it okay well nothing new there but
then they turn on the institution itself
they're not turning I don't
think my understanding my impression
anyway from the time when I would
collaborate with the Manos swamp was
they're not turning on the institution
my impression my understanding I mean I
mean some of them are even married to
this day my understanding was that
it's just a bad deal and when guys get
together and they swap notes and they
have conversations about deals that are
available out there to them then they
just say I'm not turning on I'm just not
doing it right turning on it is in my
estimation very very different than just
not inviting it into your life but he's
trying to conflate those two things
anyway an institution fundamental to
human FL flourishing male flourishing
the flourishing of children and the
flourish of society an institution that
has when rightly ordered the great
metaphor of our relationship with Christ
here we go with the religious stuff
there were some notes
here um that I took from a video that
Matt Walsh literally just published um
shortly before I went live I think in
the last half an hour um actually I'll
I'll save that for a minute let me just
finish reading the Tweet so I can sort
of segue into that marriage makes men
men marriage saves men and is a picture
of the Salvation of men how does
marriage make men men let's just ask
ourselves this question for a moment
let's let's just marinate on that how
does getting married make a man a man
like what defines a man like how is it
that a marriage defines a man I'm
genuinely curious and chat you guys let
me know right now how you see marriage
defining because I don't see marriage
making a man making a
man maybe becoming a father is what he's
trying to say makes you a man but
getting married how does that make you a
man you know they're they're they're
they're trying to propose here that
marriage has been around since the
beginning of time this is this is one of
the sound bites that I heard Matt Walsh
just say in his last uh published
video and uh thousands of years tens of
thousands of
years marriage isn't that old of an
institution I mean humans have been
around a lot longer than marriage has
been around uh
roughly since the time of
Agriculture right uh you know we've
we've been talking about this notion of
something that looks like marriage
except for back then the interests seem
to be more around the notion of
blending uh in-laws right uh there's a
book Stephanie coun wrote I talk about
it in my book The unplugged Alpha it's
called marriage a history and throughout
the vast majority of time it wasn't
about making men men or saving men or
the salvation of men like Jeremy boring
says here it was about the acquisition
of in-laws there wasn't much in the way
of government there wasn't much in the
way of schooling uh policing medical
care care for the elders there was no
infrastructure back then so to acquire
in-laws would have made much more sense
uh also when you had stuff because of
Agriculture like land and oxen and
chickens and goats and all this kind of
[__] um you had family to sort of pass
it down to because you generally stay
put versus before it was nomadic hun
Gathering right which is how we operated
for millions of years prior to the last
few thousand years where we got into
agriculture so marriage never made men
men right um I think it it would be safe
to argue other things in life made men
men like being able to acquire food
acquire resources um you know be
children had nothing to do with marriage
the notion of marriage came from the
notion of the acquisition of in-laws uh
her side of the family had big strong
men and some women that had some skills
maybe there was nursing skills maybe
there was uh education skills maybe
there was farming skills maybe there was
policing skills uh my side of the family
had the these skills and you would blend
the families and you would acquire
in-laws and that was that that was the
origin of it now religion you know you
can talk about religion the different
kinds of religion they all believe that
they're the right one there's thousands
of them
set that aside for a minute I don't
think for a minute that marriage makes
men men that's that's a Croc of [__] you
know I think that you and I watching
this understand that that's just a
shaming tactic it's like if you don't do
this and you're not a man
really like is
um I don't know who can we use an
example Leonardo DiCaprio is Leonardo
DiCaprio not a man because he plays the
field because he deals with younger
women and if they don't you know work
with them or whatever he just lets them
go pass you know replace is he not a man
right because I think other men want to
be him and other women want to be with
him so how is he not a man like how does
marriage make men men it it doesn't add
up it's just a straight up uh empty
argument that's a shaming tactic right
just blah blah blah right we should
fight to make marriage marriage okay so
here's the fight part of it right let's
let's keep fighting to make marriage
marriage like their version of marriage
is what they want they don't want the
state version involved in it they want
their religious version of marriage
being marriage where everybody sort of
does that and everybody else in society
does that as well so they can have a big
party together with the um you know us
crowd you know this is this is us
altogether being married we must defend
men's rights in marriage here we go with
the men's right [__] we've seen how
effective men's rights groups have been
at trying to defend men or defend men's
rights in a long-term relationship and
they've been going around for decades
now and some might argue well they've
been somewhat effective or remotely
effective or they've accomplished this
that or the other thing but at the end
of the day the truth of the matter is is
fewer people are getting married of
those that do get married they don't
live in happy long-term marriages and
the vast majority of them end up getting
divorced right if you look at the stats
when it comes to marriage so what is it
it's something like 54% end up in a
state of divorce uh second marriages
have an even higher failure rate and
then it doesn't account for the ones
that stayed married that don't either
have the option to leave or they're
staying for the kids or whatever number
of reasons they just stay they've
surveyed people I've got stats and data
on this on my uh podcast and there's
even a standalone video that I did on
the entrepreneurs and cars channel uh
and I quoted it in my book as well that
after eight years only 133% of people
report being in a state of Love meaning
I still love my wife or my girlfriend
and the woman being I am still
absolutely in love with my
husbandboyfriend whatever it happens to
be that's a shitty number by any metric
13% is a horrible number right and then
if you look at Bliss which is really
what they sell marriage as is oh it's a
state of bliss it makes men men it saves
men family love blah blah blah all this
sort of stuff so if you look at the
notion of bliss which I think is what
guys are generally sold women too you
know with Disney and princet and
princesses and all this [__] less
than 3% of people over that same period
of time eight years report being in a
state of bliss so like what exactly is
the point of this if it's got an
extremely high failure rate and for
those of them that stay together the
vast majority of them are unhappy
there's a very very small percentage of
them that are happy it's like rolling
the dice on freaking Casino uh 13 or
something like that you know the
roulette table whatever it is you're
going to play like the odds of winning
are low it it's like playing The Lottery
649 or wherever you know you happen to
live um are there people that are in
happy long-term marriages sure I know
maybe one or two you know and it came
with a series and a long sequence of
huge issues as well um there's things
that are precursors to good marriages
and I'll talk to you know that in a bit
let me just make a note here good
marriages let's talk about that
right so let's let's keep reading a
sweet we must defend men's right but we
must not abandon marriage well we must
not again US versus them it's it's us
are you in the US crowd where we must
not abandon marriage are you in the US
crowd right that's basically what he's
saying right them they're going to
abandon it us we don't abandon it we you
know we hold firm but 80% of marriages
are untied by women so you don't have
any control of that right if she says
I'm bored I want out Kevin from sales
looks good I'm banging the pool whatever
it happens to be doesn't matter but if
80% of the time the knot is untied
because women want to untie it it's not
generally men that are untying the knot
it's generally women that are untying
the knot to abandon marriage is to
abandon the fight beneath the fight we
have to fight for every [__] thing in
life right now right so we have to fight
for marriage or what or what they're
calling you know what makes men men and
all this sort of stuff the fight on
which all other fights are premised what
a Croc of [__] the fight on which all
other fights are like really really you
know anti-marriage is anti- life well
how did we get here today you know we
all exist today not because of marriage
but because a man and a woman got
together were intimate and a baby popped
out nine months later marriage had
nothing to do with that for millions of
years so saying that anti-marriage is
anti-life is just stupid it is the
dumbest thing that you could possibly
state with an ego investment in an
institution that clearly doesn't work
that's set up for failure for the most
part you cannot be conservative and
anti-marriage because they're a
conservative platform they're saying if
you're reading this and you're a
conservative you can't be on their side
you have to be on our side so this is
Jeremy boring which reads boring after
you've read it a couple times I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out